[Music]
here's something I want to ask you
something I'd like to ask you how about
we say it at the same time one two will
you prove on me what I see reach ppq our
HPV Veronica I'm just carrying it
yeah see that blonde kid over there I
dare you to blow out his candles before
he gets a chance to they homeschool
their size very important that Kevin has
a normal and complete high school
experience drop ship bugs [ __ ] hey
guys come check out this kids weird fuse
Rhys caught you a leprechaun I'm gonna
cut up your bog there so in the balls
[Music]
think that we ain't good enough win or
lose I am so proud of you you're gonna
win what game are we playing basketball
coach what color is this key why why
this is no high fidelity music playing
kids are sticking their penises in the
verge of course and then mengel's their
penises dude extensive testing any red
flags
[Music]
so the period layout of a vagina frozen
pieces foot
[Music]
you sucked off that hobo for magic being
he was wizard
[Music]
[Music]
ooop on me you don't want to be mr. to
squeeze thank you please just when I
thought it couldn't get more offensive
[Music]
how many [ __ ] times do I have to tell
you back there why don't you say it is
we just walk with the Lord I'm getting
its part already made you black gave you
a foot and a half thick dribble with
that [ __ ]
[Music]